hey guys it's Monday October 26 I'm Mary
giving our friends in Australia the week
off so they can play scary games for
Halloween lucky jerks let's talk about
the news let's start out with some
fallout 4 news it sounds like you're
going to be able to preload the game so
you can start exploring the wasteland
even sooner all versions of Bethesda's
up coming post apocalyptic role-playing
game fallout 4 will support preloading
the developer has confirmed marketing
executive Pete Hines made the
announcement on Twitter today the exact
day and time that pre-loading begins has
not been announced however hime said
this should begin a few days before the
game's November 10th release date
pre-loading has been a mainstay on PC
for years now though it's a relatively
new feature for consoles stay tuned to
find out when exactly you'll be able to
start preloading fallout 4 fans of
payday 2 were not pleased about finding
out they were microtransactions being
added to the game now produced from
overkill is trying to put out the fire
posting in a reddit AMA producer almere
listo responded to questions pertaining
to the update according to listo
overkill decided to introduce
microtransactions despite previously
saying it wouldn't do so as a result of
extended post-launch support and the
growth of its team to support this since
we released payday 2 back in 2013 the
overkill crew working on the project has
more than tripled in size he explained
as our ambition for post launch has
grown we've hired more people to help
make it happen but how do the micro
transactions work items are acquired by
unlocking safes which initially could
only be done by purchasing a special
drill for two dollars and fifty cents
since then a drill has been added as a
random drop once the safe is cracked
open the player is given a random weapon
skin or items some of which can impact
gameplay listo also indicated that the
micro transaction aspect of the game was
proving to be successful for the studio
seemingly suggesting it has no plans to
remove it we understand that there's a
lot of fury anger and disappointment
with us adding them from an economic
standpoint however completely based on
statistics we can already see that the
black market update is working as
intended going forward we
we can convince the parts of the
community that resists this change that
this was the right decision to do to
ensure the stability of overkill as an
independent developer and the future
growth of payday 2 finally if you were
sad to hear that that game with Darth
Maul was cancelled there's a new hope
developer red fly is working on a
next-gen demo to show to EA the
developers behind the cancelled star
wars game that would have starred the
nefarious 5th Lord Darth Maul is now
saying they're planning to resurrect the
title in a recent reddit AMA red fly
studio CEO and owner Danforth talked
more about the project and how he hopes
it can eventually see the light of day
in an online Q&A session forth revealed
that red fly is currently working on a
full next-gen demo of all things mall to
show to the powers that be he added it's
been a lot of work on our off time
according to a 2014 report the Darth
Maul game was in development for 360 ps3
and Wii U the new edition is presumably
for next-generation consoles well that's
all the news for today but be sure to
check back tomorrow when we'll have more
news and a metric butt ton of halo 5
coverage